RONALD SMITH: So last time,
upstairs, we did this systems
experiment where we had
a tank of water.
We tried to analyze it and
its three components--
the reservoir, the input,
and the output.
We talked about things like
steady state balance,
transient response to changes
in the input and the output.
We derived a little mathematical
relationship
describing how the outflow
depends on the
depth of the water.
We put those equations together,
we came up with a
prediction of what the
equilibrium water level would
be for various values
of flow inputs.
It worked out pretty well.
We got fairly good quantitative
agreement on that.
Are there any questions
on any of that?
So that's basic system
analysis.
We're going to apply that
idea today to the energy
budget of the Earth.
And we'll be applying it later
in the course to other simple
systems relating to the Earth.
In this one, the input
is going to
be the solar radiation.
Sometimes it's called
insolation, with an o, not
insulation, but insolation.
That's the rate at which solar
energy is approaching and then
finally being absorbed
by the Earth.
The loss is going to be the
infrared radiation to space.
We'll talk about the laws
that govern that today.
And the heat storage will be not
the whole Earth, because
it takes too long for heat
to conduct in and
out of a whole Earth--
millions, if not hundreds
of millions of years.
So really the system we're
talking about is just the skin
of the Earth, the first few
meters are in the ocean, the
first five kilometers or so.
The part that is responsive to
the heat that's being put in
and taken out.
So we will have a reservoir.
We'll have inputs, we'll
have outputs.
Now, there's one input we're
going to neglect.
There is some heat in the deep
interior of the Earth that
comes from the decay of
uranium that makes the
interior of the Earth
quite hot.
And that heat can leak out to
the surface of the Earth.
That's called geothermal heat.
That can be important for
certain subjects, but for
climate studies that
is negligible.
That's only a few-- a tiny
fraction of a watt per square
meter that reaches the Earth's
surface from the interior.
And we'll see, these fluxes
are orders of
magnitude larger than that.
So we're going to neglect
geothermal radiation--
geothermal heat from
the interior.
We're also going to assume that
the Earth has a uniform
temperature.
That's not a great assumption,
but in the beginning we're
going to just try to find a
formula that describes the
average temperature
of the Earth.
Later on we'll be dealing
with the pole to equator
temperature gradients.
But for now, the Earth
will have a
single temperature today.
And of course, we're going
to assume steady state.
So we're going to use the kind
of formulation we did with the
water tank where we understand
the inputs and outputs.
Sometimes they'll be out of
balance, but we're going to
make the assumption they'll be
in balance and use that to
solve for certain properties
of the system.
So that's the goal today, but
before I do that I've got to
talk to you about the
fundamental laws of radiation.
Now, I mentioned this the other
day when we were talking
about the stratosphere
and the thermosphere.
If you have an object like
anything in this room, or the
Sun, or any object at all, and
you plot the emitted radiation
as a function of wavelengths--
I'll use the Greek letter
lambda to represent
wavelength.
That's the distance from the
crest to crest of the wave. It
looks something like this.
I'm going to draw a bunch
of curves for different
temperatures.
These are called black
body curves.
It's also referred to sometimes
as the Plank Function.
So if you've got a book on
physics, look up black body or
look up the Plank Function and
read what it says about this.
Now, this would be for
a cooler temperature.
This would be for some
intermediate temperature.
And this would be for
a high temperature.
So for example, this might be
the surface of the Earth with
the temperature at 288 Kelvin.
This might be for the surface
of the Sun with the
temperature of 6,000
degrees Kelvin.
Notice two things about this.
When you make the temperature
greater, of course, you're
increasing the amount of
radiation that's coming out at
every wavelength.
Every wavelength the intensity
of the emitted radiation
increases with temperature.
As does the integral
under the curve.
The total sum of all the
radiation is the area under
each of these curves.
That total increases as well.
Furthermore, notice that the
peak of the curve shifts with
temperature.
It's there for the cooler
temperature, there for the
intermediate temperature,
and there for the higher
temperature.
So the color, if you like, the
color of the radiation changes
as the temperature of
the object changes.
Now, there are names for these
particular aspects of the
radiation law.
The shift in the peak is
referred to as Wien's law.
And it's given as by the
following formula.
Lambda max is equal to a
constant divided by the
temperature expressed
in Kelvins.
And this lambda is going to
be in units of microns.
A micron is 10 to the
minus 6 meters.
Before I compute an example of
that, let me just remind you
of the electromagnetic spectrum
for a second.
Wavelength increasing
to the right.
There's a range we call the
visible part of the spectrum
that runs from 0.4
to 0.7 microns.
The human eye is sensitive
to those waves.
Then, as we spoke about last
time, the ultraviolet is over
here, and the infrared
is over there.
Microwave is further over, and
then radio waves are further
over to the right, and
X-rays are here.
So just to remind you, you might
want to remember 0.4 and
0.7 as the range of the visible
part of the spectrum.
Now, let's do a calculation
here.
For the Sun, the surface
of the Sun is
approximately 6,000 Kelvin.
If I plug into that formula to
get lambda max, it's going to
be 2897 over 6,000.
That's approximately
0.48 microns.
I'll write it here as
mu m, micrometers.
And that is going to lie right
about there, roughly in the
middle of the visible range
of the spectrum.
That's kind of interesting, and
you might want to think is
that just an accident?
I'll say more about
that later.
But make a little question
mark there.
Why does it happen-- yeah?
STUDENT: What is the
6,000 again?
PROFESSOR: The surface
temperature of the Sun.
Is it just an accident?
That's my question to
you for thought.
Is it just an accident that
the Sun's peak radiation
happens to fall in the human
range of high sensitivity?
Interesting question.
Let's do the same
thing for Earth.
Typical temperature for Earth
is about 288 Kelvin.
Lambda max then is
2897 over 288.
That's an easy one to do.
That's approximately
10 microns.
That is way out--
no, that's in the infrared.
Let me not exaggerate this.
That is somewhere--
this is kind of a log
scale I've got here.
That's in the infrared part of
the spectrum, the so-called
thermal infrared.
Question?
STUDENT: Is that the surface
temperature?
PROFESSOR: This is the surface
temperature of
the Earth, 288 Kelvin.
We've used it before.
It's 15 degrees Celsius--
it's like the temperature
in this room.
Maybe we're a few degrees warmer
than that, but this is
a typical Earth-type
temperature.
So this makes a big
difference.
This means that the radiation
coming from the Sun is in one
wavelength.
And the radiation emitted by the
Earth is quite a different
wavelength altogether.
So remember that.
That's going to be a key
for understanding
the greenhouse effect.
The other law that arises
from this is called the
Stefan-Boltzmann Law.
And it relates to the total
power, the area under the
curve, power per unit
area of an object--
an object emitting--
is given by a constant--
I'll use a Greek letter
sigma for that--
times the temperature
to the fourth power.
This constant is the
Stefan-Boltzmann constant.
It's derived in physics classes
from first principles.
And the value is 5.735 times
10 to the minus 8 watts per
meter squared per Kelvins
to the fourth power.
You could look it up.
You can Google it.
If you ever forget it, you
can find it very easily.
It's a very famous physical
constant, the
Stefan-Boltzmann constant.
It will never be any problem
with knowing
what that value is.
Now before we go any further,
let's see if these two laws
make any sense.
The Stefan-Boltzmann law that
says that the total power goes
like the fourth power
of the temperature.
If I were to double the
temperature, the power would
go up by a factor of not two,
not four, not eight, but 16.
So you'd increase the power by a
factor of 16 by doubling the
temperature.
Very powerful sensitivity
to temperature.
And then Wein's law
that says that the
wavelength goes inversely.
The wavelength of maximum
radiation goes inversely with
the temperature.
The higher the temperature, the
shorter is the wavelength
that's being strongly emitted.
Now, I've got this little
light bulb over here.
And I'm just going to
hit some lights.
I've got a variable transformer,
and I've got a
light bulb that has no frost on
the glass, so you can see
the filament in there.
I can change the temperature
of the filament by how much
electrical current I
pass through it.
So when, of course, it's at room
temperature like that,
it's radiating a little bit,
but it's radiating at
wavelengths in the infrared
for which
the eye is not sensitive.
Then as I gradually increase the
temperature, you can begin
to see it there.
There's a little bit now in
the visible part of the
spectrum, but it's red.
Remember that diagram--
I should have put--
let me just back up and get
that up here for a second.
On this end of the spectrum is
the red, and this is the blue.
So originally the wavelength
being emitted is here, now it
begins to move over.
As I increase the temperature
you begin to see some red.
Then as I continue to move it
over, at some point you'll be
seeing equal amounts
in all of the--
in all the parts of the
visible spectrum.
So there it's becoming white.
Because that peak has moved
over, centered on the visible
part of the spectrum.
Notice it's also very
much brighter.
So with this one little device,
we are looking at both
the Stefan-Boltzmann
law and Wien's law.
They're both illustrated by
this little experiment.
Any questions on that?
So all I'm doing is changing
the temperature of the
filament and what I'm seeing is
an increase in power and a
shift in the wavelength from the
red into the center of the
visible part of the spectrum.
Yes, question.
STUDENT: Why does it appear to
turn white when it does,
directly after going
to yellow?
PROFESSOR: Well remember,
think of this
peak sliding over.
So first you see only the red,
then you begin to see some red
and some green is
in the middle.
That's going to give you yellow
when you get the red
and the green together.
Then finally, when you get an
equal set of all red, green
and blue, that looks white.
So white light, as Newton
figured out, is the sum, an
equal sum of all the visible
parts of the spectrum.
So we're just seeing that happen
as we shift that peak
over and center it on the
visible part of the spectrum.
Yes.
STUDENT: Does the
Stefan-Boltzmann Law give
brightness or power?
What is power?
PROFESSOR: Power is the emitted
power, it's the power
in that radiation.
It's the rate at which energy is
being sent from the object
out into space with
electromagnetic radiation.
You can think of as brightness
if you like, but brightness
usually refers to how something
is perceived by the
human eye, and that's not
our context here.
Our context here is
an energy budget.
How much energy is being lost.
So I'm going to use the word
power there instead
of brightness.
Anything else on this?
Well now I think we're
ready to do--
oh, well there is one other
thing maybe we should do while
we remember.
Some of you may not even believe
me when I tell you
that all the objects in this
room are emitting.
They're just not emitting
at a wavelength that the
human eye can see.
What do you see?
You see light reflecting
off various objects.
That's not what I'm talking
about here.
Objects yes, objects can reflect
light coming from
light bulbs and so on.
But I'm talking about the
emission of radiation.
That's a different process
than reflection.
So this is just an infrared
thermometer.
It's not much different than the
one you use to take your
own temperature or the
temperature of a child.
It measures the temperature of
an object by measuring the
intensity of the radiation
that's being emitted.
So it measures emitted
radiation.
Then from this curve, it
figures out what the
temperature must have
been in order to
radiate that intensely.
So when I look at this table--
by the way, I have to warn
you of something.
There is a little
laser in there.
See the red dot?
But that's just to
help you aim it.
It doesn't play any role in the
measurement whatsoever.
It just aims so you know
what object it is that
you're aiming at.
But please don't aim
this in your eye.
So anyway, the temperature of
this table is 24 Celsius.
Temperature of my hand
is 30 Celsius.
Try it yourself.
I'll pass that around.
Anyway, that little gadget is a
perfect illustration of the
physical process I'm
talking about.
It's an object emitting
radiation in proportion to its
temperature--
in proportion to its
temperature.
Higher temperature, more
radiation is being emitted.
Now I think we're ready to
do the main part of the
derivation.
I'm going to re-draw the Earth
here a little smaller.
We're going to assume that
the Sun's radiation--
radiant beams are coming in
parallel to each other.
Because the Sun is so far away
from us, we can assume that
those rays are actually parallel
by the time they
reach the Earth.
Therefore, they're going to
hit the Earth and cast a
shadow out into outer space
behind the Earth.
The radiation that's missing
there is going to be the
radiation that hits the Earth.
Now, the reason I'm saying it
that way is that you might be
a little bit confused because
this Earth's surface is a
sphere, and some of the
radiation is hitting it in a
normal direction, some
of it is hitting it
in a oblique direction.
For the moment, I don't
care about that.
I just want to know the total
amount of radiation that hits
the object independent
of where it hits and
what angle it hits.
The easiest way to do that is
just to imagine that the Earth
is casting a shadow and has
removed that amount of
radiation from the beam.
So the solar constant, the
intensity of the radiation
from the Sun at the orbital
position of the Earth is about
1,380 watts per square meter.
In other words, if you go
outside the atmosphere facing
the Sun and draw a square meter,
there's 1,380 watts of
radiant energy passing through
that square meter.
If you had two square meters, it
would be twice that value.
So that's on a per
unit area basis.
The area of this shadow
then is just a circle.
It's pi r squared where r is
the radius of the planet.
So the intercepted radiation is
given by the product of S
pi r squared.
S is a solar constant,
pi r squared is
the intercepted area.
I want to illustrate
that for a second.
I'm going to hit the
lights again here.
I just have a source of light
that's nearly parallel and I
have my globe here.
Now the Earth is spinning on
its axis of course, and its
tilt may change with the
seasons, but basically it's
casting a shadow as
you see there.
That shadow is just related to
the projected area of this
sphere, which is pi r squared,
the area of a circle.
So that's all I've done here is
just to compute the total
radiation hitting that globe
by using the idea
of casting a shadow.
Questions on that?
Pretty simple idea.
Now, some of that radiation,
however,
is going to be reflected.
And we define here something
called the albedo.
Albedo is the average
reflectivity of a planet.
It can be expressed as a decimal
or as a percent.
I'll give you a number
for Earth.
For planet Earth the albedo is
approximately 0.33, or you
could call that 33%.
Approximately 33% of the
radiation that hits the Earth
reflects off.
And because that heat then
doesn't really enter the
Earth, doesn't really add energy
to the Earth, we're
going to drop that off.
So that was the intercepted
radiation.
The absorbed radiation then is
S pi r squared times 1 minus
the albedo.
If 33% is reflected, well
then, 67% is absorbed.
That's the 1 minus the albedo.
It's the other part.
The amount reflected is S pi
r squared A, and the part
absorbed is S pi r squared
1 minus A. So we've just
partitioned that radiation, the
part that is absorbed and
the part that is reflected.
Now, let's try to compute what
the emitted radiation is.
We're going to assume that the
surface of the earth is a
black body.
It emits according to the
Stefan-Boltzmann law.
So we have to get the area--
remember, this is
per unit area--
we need to find the area
that is emitting.
The area that is emitting
is not the
projected area of the sphere.
It's the actual area
of a sphere.
What is the expression for the
surface area of a sphere?
Anybody remember?
STUDENT: 4 pi r squared.
PROFESSOR: 4 pi r
squared, right.
So the area we're talking about
here is 4 pi r squared,
and so the emitted radiation
then is going to be 4 pi r
squared times sigma times T
to the fourth using the
Stefan-Boltzmann law.
Questions so far?
Yes.
STUDENT: For the surface area
thing, we're including the
entire Earth, even though
the Sun's only
shining on half of it?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
That's right.
Remember, I've assumed here that
the Earth has a uniform
temperature, and since the
emission depends only on the
temperature, we're going
to use the entire
surface of the Earth.
After all, even in the real
world, when expressed in
Kelvins, that temperature
is not so different.
This might be 310 Kelvin, this
might be 250 Kelvin, but out
of a range of 300, so that's
not a huge difference.
So this is not a huge problem.
It's not great, but it's not a
huge problem, the assumption
of uniform temperature.
Well, I think you know what I'm
going to do now because of
what I did in the
tank experiment.
I have laws that govern the
input and the output, and I'm
going to assume steady state and
see what kind of a-- how
does a system come
into equilibrium?
So I'm making the steady
state assumption.
Simply, all I have to do is
balance the emitted radiation,
which has units, by the way, of
watts with the intercepted
or the absorbed radiation,
which has units of watts.
So I will simply equate
those two.
I'm going to write S pi r
squared 1 minus the albedo is
now equal to, this is the
statement of steady state, 4
pi r squared sigma
T to the fourth.
That's the profound and
very useful step.
And I could then go the next
step and solve mathematically
for the temperature
of the planet.
So let me do that.
First of all, notice that the
pi r squares are going to
cancel out from both sides
of the equation.
In other words, the result is
not going to depend on the
radius of the planet.
Why is that?
Well, the larger the planet
is, the more radiation it
receives from the Sun, but
the more effectively
it radiates to space.
And those two things
exactly cancel out.
So there's no direct impact
of the size of the planet.
Notice that four remains,
however.
That important difference
between the projected area of
a sphere and the surface area
of the sphere, that stays in
our calculation.
Now let me bring T to the
fourth over here on the
left-hand side.
That's going to be S times 1
minus albedo over 4 sigma.
Have I done that right?
Divide through by 4 sigma.
Then the final step would be
to take the fourth root of
that equation.
So I'm going to write it as T
equals bracket 1 minus the
albedo over 4 sigma
to the 1/4 power.
That is a prediction based on
some simple laws of physics
for how hot each temperature in
the solar-- each planet in
the solar system will be.
You need to know the solar
constant for that planet, and
of course, the further away
from the Sun you are, the
smaller will be that value.
You need to know the albedo of
the planet, how much radiation
does it reflect.
And then you need to know the
Stefan-Boltzmann constant, but
that's a universal constant so
that doesn't change from
planet to planet.
STUDENT: And the sigma is
the Stefan-Boltzmann--
PROFESSOR: So let's put some
numbers in here for Earth.
What am I using for
solar constant?
1,380.
The albedo for Earth is 0.33.
This is a formula for which
you're going to want
to check the units.
I haven't put the units up here,
but you should do that
to be sure all the units
are going to work out.
That should be just
in Kelvins.
So when you do all the unit
crossings out, you should get
something just in
units of Kelvin.
Leave an inch in your notes
to check on that.
I worked this out and that's
about 252 Kelvins, predicted
temperature for Earth.
Questions on that calculation?
Remember all the assumptions
that went into it.
These, as well as assuming that
the Earth emits like a
black body, because
we used that.
Now, if you convert that to
Celsius, that's minus 21
degrees Celsius.
That's a little too
cold, right?
Remember, the actual temperature
for Earth is
something around 288
Kelvin, which is
about 15 degrees Celsius.
Now if you look at this in the
Celsius-- in the Kelvin scale,
252 versus 288, that seems like
a pretty good estimate.
It's only off by 10% or 15%,
something like that.
But if you look at it in terms
of Celsius, it looks like a
bad approximation.
Why is that?
Because remember, the
Celsius scale--
zero on the Celsius scale
is based at the
freezing point for water.
Whether water is frozen or not
is a big deal for us on Earth.
So this prediction with the
assumptions I made indicates
the earth would be in a
permanently frozen state.
All the water on it would be
frozen, whereas this would say
most of the water's going to
be in the liquid state.
So it's a big deal to think of
it in terms of Celsius or in
terms of water, but it's not
such a bad approximation if
you think of it in terms of
absolute temperature.
Now what do you think is the
reason for the error?
Where have I gone wrong
with this calculation?
Anybody in the back?
Yeah.
STUDENT: You're assuming
no geothermal heat?
PROFESSOR: No.
I did make that assumption, but
it turns out that that's a
very good assumption.
So that's not the problem.
Yes.
STUDENT: Are you assuming that
it's like a black body?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
What's the catch word there?
So yeah, the greenhouse
effect.
So the planet has
an atmosphere.
I've neglected the
atmosphere here.
What the atmosphere does on our
planet and others is that
when the radiation is emitted
from the Earth's surface,
instead of letting all of that
escape, it stops some of it,
it absorbs it, and sends some
of it back to Earth again.
It's as if that object is not
able to radiate with its full
black body potential.
Something's holding that heat
in, and it's the greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere.
So obviously, we're going to
be coming back to this time
and time again in the course.
But this important discrepancy
is largely due to our neglect
of the atmosphere, that is
to say our neglect of the
greenhouse effect.
Let me give a very brief
description of how the
greenhouse effect works
on planet Earth.
And then we'll take a quick look
at some other planets to
see if other planets have a
greenhouse effect as well.
So once again, this is
wavelength versus intensity of
radiation emitted.
For Earth's temperature,
the curve looks
something like that.
For the Sun's temperature it
looks something like that.
We've already talked about this
shift in the wavelength
of maximum emission.
But let me put underneath this
some of the absorptive
properties of the Earth's
atmosphere.
On the same wavelength scale,
I'm going to draw here the
percent absorbed as radiation
tries to pass through the
atmosphere.
In other words, I'm looking at
a segment of the atmosphere
and imagining radiation is
either coming in and trying to
penetrate to the Earth's
surface, or it's trying to get
out and escape.
Either one, it doesn't matter
what direction it's moving,
but some fraction of the
radiation's going to be
absorbed as it tries to pass
through the atmosphere.
That's the faction I'm going
to plot on the y-axis here.
Now, the visible part of the
spectrum is about here.
Let's call that the
visible part.
I'm going to need
these guidelines
to help me be accurate.
Here's 100%.
Basically, this absorption
curve looks
something like this.
I'm just making some random
wiggles here.
There are a few areas that are
nearly transparent in the
wavelength spectrum.
And then you get to the radio
waves and it comes way down.
So this is very schematic.
I haven't meant to be
quantitative on this.
The point is that most of the
Sun's radiation falls in a
part of the spectrum for which
the Earth's atmosphere is
transparent.
When this percent absorption
is low, that means the
atmosphere is transparent.
On the other hand, when the
Earth tries to radiate back
out to space, because it's
cooler, it radiates at a
longer wavelength.
That wavelength tends to fall
in a region where there's a
lot of atmospheric absorption.
The atmosphere is almost
opaque at those longer
wavelengths.
So it's a bit like
a one-way valve.
I don't like that analogy,
but let me say it and
then correct it.
It's really like a
one-way valve.
The radiation coming from the
Sun can pass through the
atmosphere and heat the Earth.
Now I'm neglecting the little
bit that's ultraviolet that
heats the stratosphere, a little
bit of the X-rays that
heats the thermosphere.
The bulk of the radiation comes
right on through and
hits the surface of the Earth.
But when the Earth tries to
radiate out to space, most of
that radiation is absorbed and
it has to be re-emitted before
it can finally escape
from the planet.
Now, I don't like the term
one-way valve because that
implies that it makes a
difference what direction the
radiation is moving in, and
that's not the point at all.
The point is that these are at
two different wavelengths.
Absorption doesn't depend on
what direction the photons are
moving, but it does depend
on their wavelength.
So the short wavelength can
penetrate, the longer
wavelengths cannot.
And that's the origin, or that's
the physics behind the
greenhouse effect.
Yes.
STUDENT: Does it enter the
atmosphere and then--?
PROFESSOR: Enter and
penetrate through.
When I say penetrate--
STUDENT: And hit the surface?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So this radiation will come
through all the way to the
Earth's surface.
There it will be absorbed.
It'll heat the Earth's surface
and then that heat will come
back up and heat the atmosphere
and so on.
But the point is it gets all the
way through the atmosphere
without being absorbed.
It isn't until it hits
the Earth's surface
that it gets absorbed.
Thanks for that clarification.
This is the atmosphere only
I'm talking about.
All those radiations,
of course, cannot
penetrate into the Earth.
They're absorbed immediately
when they
hit the Earth's surface.
Yes.
STUDENT: So you're saying that
the longer wavelengths--?
PROFESSOR: Cannot penetrate
through the atmosphere.
STUDENT: So they don't go
through-- do they get into the
atmosphere?
PROFESSOR: They do.
They get part way--
for example, this happens to
be radiation trying to get
out, because it's the
longer stuff.
So let's just imagine for a
moment, you've got the Earth's
surface radiating at,
say, 10 microns,
wavelength of 10 microns.
It'll penetrate up a few hundred
meters or maybe even a
kilometer into the atmosphere,
but it'll get absorbed.
It'll heat the air there, the
air will then re-radiate some
up and some down.
And some of the down will come
all the way back and add a
source of heat to the surface.
So the fact that--
I'm not saying it can't
penetrate a little bit.
It'll penetrate on average tens,
hundreds, maybe even a
few thousand meters, but it
won't get all the way out for
the most part.
That's not 100%.
Some will get out, but
most will not.
There are few special parts
of the spectrum that are
transparent, even to these
longer waves, and we refer to
those as windows.
For example, the most famous
one, the so-called infrared
window is from 8
to 12 microns.
It's a fairly narrow window.
It's only 4 microns in width.
And out there that's
not very much.
But there, that particular
wavelength
can penetrate through.
And this gadget, by the
way, you might ask
why does this work?
If there's such a thing as
atmospheric absorption, then
how come the radiation emitted
from the surface hasn't been
absorbed before it gets
to the instrument?
This instrument is designed
to work in
that particular window.
But it's a narrow window, and I
had to use special optics to
get it just to work
in that window.
So be careful, the atmosphere
is not opaque to every
wavelength, but to most
wavelengths out in the
infrared part of the spectrum.
Any questions there?
I think I have time to
put up a small table.
I'm going to keep this final
formula here because that's
the one that I used to
construct the table.
Planet, albedo, predicted
temperature, and the actual
temperature, and something
about the
atmosphere of the planet.
Venus, Earth, and Mars.
We'll just do those three
Earth-like planets.
The albedo for these planets
are 0.71, 0.33, and 0.17.
Venus is a very bright planet,
if you look at in the sky.
It's very often the brightest
object in the sky because it
reflects radiation
so strongly.
We see that represented by that
high albedo number there.
The Earth we've already
spoken about.
Some of that reflectivity comes
from the clouds in our
atmosphere, which are
quite bright.
Mars is a rather dark planet,
Mars with an s, because there
are very few clouds
in its atmosphere.
So it's only the surface itself
that we're dealing with
when we're computing
the albedo.
When I put the--
I haven't written the
solar constant.
Remember, S is different for
each of these planets as well,
but when I put the appropriate
S in there and use that
albedo, here's what I get
from this formula.
I get 244, 252--
we've done that one--
and 216.
And here's the actual.
The actual observed surface
temperature for these planets.
Mars is pretty good.
We predict 216, the
actual is 230.
There is a little bit of a
greenhouse effect on Mars, but
it's not terribly strong.
The Earth we've already
spoken about.
That's a pretty big difference
when you express it in Celsius
and think about the properties
of water.
But look at Venus.
We are not even close.
Not even in a Kelvin scale
does that look like a
reasonable estimate.
That's because Venus has
the granddaddy of
all greenhouse effects.
That huge difference is due
to the effect of Venus's
atmosphere trapping infrared
radiation as it tries to leave
the surface.
Let me just mention here,
Venus has a massive CO2
atmosphere.
Earth has a moderate intensity,
mostly air, but
with some greenhouse gases
like H20, CO2, et cetera.
I have to erase this now.
And Mars has a thin
CO2 atmosphere.
CO2 is a greenhouse gas, but
because the atmosphere of Mars
is so thin, the greenhouse
effect is not particularly
strong on Mars.
So there we have it.
We have the fact that the
greenhouse effect is-- occurs
on all planets that
have atmospheres.
It tends to make the planet's
surface temperature warmer
than it would otherwise be.
The physics of it has to do with
radiation being able to
penetrate through
the atmosphere.
The Sun's radiation versus the
radiation that's emitted by
the planet.
Then it depends on the nature of
the atmosphere how much of
a greenhouse gas you're
going to have. CO2's
a greenhouse gas.
The surface pressure on Venus
is something like 60 times
that of Earth.
Has a very massive atmosphere,
and it's almost all CO2.
You can just imagine
you're going to--
kind of like the worst possible
scenario for having a
very strong greenhouse gas.
Not only is there a lot of it,
but almost all of it is an
absorbing gas.
I have to say a few words--
I think I can squeeze it in--
about what is a greenhouse gas
because I use that term
loosely now.
It needs to be defined.
It's basically a gas
that can absorb and
emit infrared radiation.
What determines whether
a gas can do that is
its molecular structure.
So for example, an Argon atom
just by itself, because it's
only a single point mass, it
cannot rotate, it can't
vibrate, it can just
move around.
And by moving around, it doesn't
radiate any energy.
Nitrogen, N2, two point masses
held by a chemical bond.
It can rotate, it can vibrate,
but because it's a symmetric
molecule, it's electrical
charge distribution is
symmetric and it has
no dipole moment.
A dipole moment is a separation
of charges.
If I've got a positive and a
negative charge and they've
been moved apart, then
we say that object
has a dipole moment.
But you need to break symmetry
in the molecule before you can
have a dipole moment, and
nitrogen is a perfectly
symmetric molecule.
Nitrogen, nitrogen, symmetry,
no dipole moment.
Oxygen, same problem, right?
Perfectly symmetric molecule,
no dipole moment.
Look at this.
The primary constituents of
our atmosphere, nitrogen
first, oxygen second, Argon
third, none of them have a
dipole moment, none of
them can absorb or
emit infrared radiation.
These are not greenhouse
gases.
It doesn't matter much how much
of these you have. What
are the greenhouse gases then?
Well CO2, which has a
structure like this.
That's a greenhouse gas.
Why, do you say?
It looks symmetric,
doesn't it?
But it can vibrate.
If that carbon vibrates to the
left and that oxygen vibrates
to the right, suddenly
I've broken symmetry.
And I can have a dipole moment,
and that will absorb
and emit infrared radiation.
What about water vapor?
H2O.
Oxygen, two hydrogens.
Well, that's symmetric,
isn't it?
Well no, not about that axis.
It's not symmetric
about that axis.
So it'll have a dipole moment.
And it will absorb and
emit radiation.
So see, the distinction I want
to make here is between gases
that are so simple in their
structure that they can never,
no matter what they do, they
can't generate a dipole
moment, they can't get
a charge separation.
Remember, when you're talking
on your cell phone, you're
transmitting radiation.
There's an antenna in there
that's creating a dipole
moment-- positive, negative,
positive, negative, positive,
negative, and that is what is
emitting the radiation.
When you're listening, the
same thing is happening.
That radiation is
coming to you.
It's being captured by the
antenna in the cell phone with
a dipole moment.
So it's exactly the
same physics.
In all cases, you have to have
an oscillating dipole moment
if you want to absorb
or emit radiation.
Air cannot do it, but these
greenhouse gases can.
We're out of time, but
we'll pick up on
the theme next meeting.